today's one-minute Monday is be  confident so it's getting ready to  record this video I looked at myself in  the mirror and I thought to myself it's  time to shave but then I thought back to  when I was first getting started in  business I always felt like I had to  wear a suit it was always a blue suit  with a red tie very presidential and I  felt like if I wore this suit people  would take me more seriously  slowly I evolved and started to adopt a  more business casual look and now  whether I'm meeting with presidents of  Fortune 500 companies speaking in front  of an audience of thousands or just  making youtube videos for you guys I'm  usually in my hoodie or t-shirt because  my confidence comes not from my clothes  but from knowing deep down that I can  help the person that I'm speaking with  yours should to belief if you want more  entrepreneur goodness check out the link  to my newsletter below see you there  you